these herbs are what we've been using
for thousands thousands of years those
holding this Native American ceremony
believed a puff of tobacco smoke will
cleanse guests taking part the local
mountains take their name from the Rama
Pola not a nation but this field
barely an hour's drive from Manhattan is
all that's been left to them for them
this land is sacred what about this land
I mean how important is that to well
it's very important it's the last drop
of land we have that we can openly and
freely do ceremony on despite having a
permit to use the land for religious and
cultural purposes the tribe started
receiving fines and tickets in 2016 I
was surprised at the level of the
animosity and and the desire to remove
us because if you look at the houses
around here I mean there's nothing for
them to fear we weren't asking them to
move from day one it was a desire on
their part to basically get rid of us
the tribe is officially recognized by
the state of New Jersey and its ties to
the land which now sits in the midst of
this private gated community go back
generations the very name of the
township Malwa comes from the law not a
word for meeting place nevertheless
their neighbors continued to complain
about the gatherings and the fines began
to add up after a few years totaling
more than four million dollars the
Neighborhood Association in the town
neither of whom would speak to Al
Jazeera sued the tribe but then a
turning point for their legal team the
US Justice Department came to their
defense and when you have the Department
of Justice coming in and saying well
what we see appears to be happening here
is a violation of the right to religious
freedom that's something a federal court
judge is going to take very seriously in
a settlement the township agreed to drop
all fines and allow the ceremonies to
continue while the neighborhood
associations lawsuit was thrown out of
court now the tribe is suing the
neighbors for violating its right to
gather and pray
I'm hopeful for a better tomorrow I
don't know it's gonna depend on how our
neighbors respond it's just been ugly
right up until this moment but for now
it's seen as the tribes prayers have
been answered
Kristen salumi al Jazeera Mahwah New
Jersey